hey valuetainers Happy Thanksgiving from  our value team and family to yours we  are super grateful for each and every  one of you and our community and we  decided why not give back to our local  community we actually provided meals for  the Broward Healthy Start Coalition and  the children Diagnostics and treatment  center and of course we're collecting  Toys for Tots in our local community  again we are super grateful for each and  every one of you thank you for  subscribing and be a part of the family  Happy Thanksgiving Happy Thanksgiving  Happy Thanksgiving Happy Thanksgiving  Happy Thanksgiving Happy turkey day  Happy Thanksgiving Happy Thanksgiving  Happy Thanksgiving from value team  [Music]  foreign